past few years have been a little bit
tough for me
i have many small gaps
and short employment in my career
i even have a huge two-year career gap
due to some health issues
however i think the dark times are now
behind me
hi i'm cordana rujek i live in raleigh
north carolina and working as a business
analyst at lavatory
this is my second job since i completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics i simply learned with virgie
university in december 2021
my experience with simpler was great
the life classes were my favorite
because they were very interactive and i
could connect with instructors
the course had a comprehensive
curriculum i could also record the
classes for future reference the final
project were practical and advantages
with flexible deadlines for competition
my understanding of all the concept was
enhanced as a result of this and 65
scrum master ecba product owner and
agile coach
in the near future i would like to see
myself grow as a business analyst
to be totally honest with you
reviving my professional career was not
an easy task
but life go on and you need to trust
yourself and keep pushing
it doesn't matter how challenging the
path may be keep upscaling and one day
you will achieve success in life